[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a Guatemala y es
que Estados Unidos incluyó en su lista
Engel a 60 funcionarios y exempleados
públicos del Salvador Honduras Guatemala
y Nicaragua los acusa de ser corruptos y
antidemocráticos la inclusión en la
lista implica que ninguna de las
personas podrá entrar a territorio
estadounidense ni tener visados para
viajar a ese país conectamos entonces a
esta hora con ciudad de Guatemala donde
está Andrés Suárez nuestro
corresponsales Centroamérica Andrés
bienvenido y es un gusto saludarlo
hablemos de la trascendencia de la lista
Engel Qué implicaciones tiene para los
gobiernos de Centroamérica este listado
Y de qué le sirve estos señalamientos a
Estados Unidos
María Clara Buenas noches un gusto bueno
el Washington post pone a la lista Engel
como La amenaza de los Estados Unidos
para salvaguardar para cuidar las
democracias de los países
centroamericanos en otras palabras es un
listado que incluye a individuos
señalados de corrupción antidemocráticos
que a futuro puedan llegar a ser
judicializados en Estados Unidos es una
Clara intimidación a los altos
funcionarios cercanos al poder de estos
países centroamericanos y se debe ver es
con esta lupa no solamente como el
castigo de que se le revoque la Visa O
de que no puedan ser elegibles para un
proceso de visa hacia los Estados Unidos
el claro ejemplo de la importancia de la
lista Engel es el del ex presidente
hondureño Juan Orlando Hernández quien
hace un año exactamente en julio de 2021
fue incluido en la lista Engel su nombre
fue oculto y volvió a aparecer hasta
enero de 2022 cuando es reemplazado por
Xiomara y Por qué es importante el
nombre de Juan Orlando Hernández bueno
justamente el proceso en su contra
comienza con la gran acusación que el
departamento de estado de los Estados
Unidos realiza en el congreso y es el
Congreso quien decide si se extradita o
no pero el hecho de que su nombre haya
estado incluido en la lista Engel
influye en la votación del Congreso y
promovió que el expresidente haya sido
extraditado a Estados Unidos Andrés
usted ya nos daba un adelanto pero igual
Quiero preguntarle de los 60 nombres de
altos funcionarios y empresarios
cercanos al poder en estos cuatro países
Cuáles son los más destacables y cómo
afectan a los actores gobiernos de
Centroamérica
bueno empecemos por ejemplo con El
Salvador hay uno de los nombres uno de
los nombres más destacados es el de
Cristian Guevara él es diputado de la
asamblea legislativa también es el jefe
del partido de nayib bukele ideas nuevas
nuevas ideas que está acusado de haber
sido la persona que promulgó promovió la
ley en contra de los periodistas en el
estado de excepción que puedan llegar a
ser encarcelados hasta por 15 años y
difunden mensajes de las pandillas en
Guatemala por ejemplo se encuentra José
Rafael curruchiche actual jefe de la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
acusado de obstrucción de todo tipo de
investigaciones en Honduras varios de
los implicados por haber
malversado 500 mil dólares de un
programa presidencial destinado a la
Pobreza más de 500 mil dólares y en
Nicaragua 23 jueces y Fiscales que
fueron aquellos que les imputaron cargos
falsos y encarcelaron a grandes
dirigentes de la oposición en el marco
de las elecciones que llevaron a Daniel
Ortega a la presidencia de Nicaragua
grandes nombres entonces agregados a la
lista Engel Andrés gracias por el
reporte